in this video of USMLE high yield series
let's talk about gout
gout is a recurrent attack of acute
monoarticular arthritis
resulting from intra-articular
deposition of monosodium urate crystals
this deposition leads to inflammation of
joints and pain
risk factors of gout include
obesity and male gender binge drinking
of alcohol
and post menopausal status in females
let's understand the biology of gout
when RNA or DNA are broken down they
form pyrimidines and purines
purines particularly undergo a series of
catabolic reactions to yield hypoxanthin
and guanine this hypoxanthin and guanine
lead to formation of uric acid
by any chance if uric acid starts to
accumulate in the body by increased
production of decreased excretion the
levels of uric acid in the blood Rises
that is known as hyperuricemia
hyperuricemia leads to deposition of
uric acid crystals in joint leading to
gout deposition of crystals in brain
leading to psychiatric manifestations
like aggression self-mutilation
uric acid stones are excreted through
kidney as in red orange crystals
and they can also cause tense muscles as
in dystonia
hematological complication includes
faulty utilization of vitamin B12
utilization leading to metabolic
megaloblastic anemia in this video we
are talking about the joint
manifestation of hyperuricemia that is
gout
let's understand the pathology of gout
hyperuricemia leads to deposition of
unit crystals in the joint leading to
Joint inflammation clinical features
include
erythematous swollen and tender joints
common joints include a first
metatarsopharyngeal joint midfoot joints
ankle joints knee joints and wrist
joints can also be involved
but the hip joint and shoulder joint are
rarely involved
gout in long term can lead to deposition
of uret crystals in a soft tissue
leading to formation of tofi
and unit crystals in kidney can give
rise to renal stones or urate
nephropathy
let us know how we diagnose a case of
gout
diagnosis involves blood test where we
measure the level of uric acid in the
blood a level more than equal to 7.5 mg
per deciliter indicates hyperuricemia
but in gout there can be cases where
uric acid levels are normal
so we go for radiological Imaging on
Radiology if we see erosion of cortical
bones known as rat bite erosion that
indicates towards gout
definite diagnosis involves aspiration
of joint affected joint fluid and
analyzing
negatively birefringent needle shaped
crystals which are monosodium urate
crystals
once we have diagnosed gout or gouty
arthritis we have to keep in mind that a
very similar condition is also present
which is known as pseudo gout
whereas gout occurs due to deposition of
uric acid crystals pseudogout occurs due
to deposition of cppd crystals
gout is more common in male gender binge
drinking Etc where pseudogout occurs in
hyperparathyroidism and hemochromatosis
gout crystals are needle shaped and
negatively birefringent whereas
pseudogout
cppd crystals are rhomboid and
positively birefringent
in gout most commonly involved joint is
forced to a foot whereas in case of
pseudogout knee and wrist are usually
affected first
once we have ruled out the differential
diagnosis let's proceed towards
treatment
now
while treating gout we have to keep in
mind we have to manage an acute attack
of gout and once we have managed that we
have to proceed towards chronic
management of gout acute attack of gout
involves painful swollen and inflamed
inflamed joints we treat them using
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs or
NSAIDs
colchicine can be used when NSAIDs are
contraindicated as in case of unit
nephropathy or NSAID allergy if
colchicine is not working then we can go
for corticosteroids as in severe cases
once we have managed acute attack of
gout we proceed towards the definite
treatment or The Chronic management of
gout which involves decreasing the level
of uric acid in the blood
that can be achieved by using drugs such
as allopurinol and fabricsostat which
inhibit the xanthine oxidase enzyme if
you want to learn more about the
medicines used in treatment of gout you
can follow the video present on the I
button on the right hand upper corner of
this video
by now I believe we have got a overall
idea of gout
to get notes and flash cards you can
follow us on our Instagram and Facebook
page at animated biology with Urban the
link will be in the description box also
we need your support to make free high
quality content you can support us using
the super thanks icon on the bottom
right corner of the video using PayPal
paytm or UPI also you can support us on
our patreon page
to get in touch you can use the
following links this video was proudly
made in collaboration with the nerd
medic you can follow the channel on
YouTube until then bye bye see you in
the next one